MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to our
first Make The Web
Fast episode.
My name is Ilya Grigorik.
I'm a developer advocate with
the creatively titled Make The
Web Fast team, and with me--
JUSTIN CUTRONI: My name
is Justin Cutroni.
I'm the analytics advocate.
Slightly different than
a developer advocate.
And I work on the Google
Analytics team.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Awesome.
So Justin, I'm really excited
about our episode today
because I think it covers two
topics that are the most near
and dear to my heart,
which is web
performance and web analytics.
And I don't say those just
because I think Google
Analytics is awesome--
which it is--
but also because anytime
you talk about the web
optimization field or any sort
of optimization, you really
have to have good tools.
You have to measure, and you
have to understand and
quantify what it is that
you're trying to do.
Otherwise you're just
working in the dark.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Yeah.
I'm really excited, because
we're going to hopefully tell
people how to make their
businesses better and their
websites better.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
And I guess that's the other
component, right?
Like us developers like to
optimize our sites to go
faster and faster, but at a
certain point, you have to ask
the question of how
does it relate to
the business as well?
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Dollars
and cents.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Dollars
and cents, right.
So hopefully you'll
keep us honest.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: We'll try.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Also, I think
it's a very good episode to
kick off our series with
because, as I mentioned, you
really need to have
good tools.
And Google Analytics gives you
a lot of power, and that's
what we're going to
talk about today.
So there are three broad topics
that I want to make
sure that we cover today.
The first one is just
what are the tools?
What do we mean by web
performance optimization?
And what are the metrics
that we need to track?
The second one is real user
measurement, which is perhaps
a very obvious concept to a
lot of people in analytic
space, but perhaps not so
obvious to people like
developers, just because we
haven't had access to a lot of
this data in the past.
And then the last one is,
of course, to tie it all
together, Google Analytics.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Yep.
And I'll cover that part.
We'll talk about the business,
and how all of these great
technical things that Ilya's
going to tell you about in
terms of speed and performance
optimization can be measured
in terms of dollars and cents,
literally, for your business.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
OK.
So with that, we do have
some slides that
we're going to go through.
Just a little bit
of housekeeping.
You can find both Justin and
myself on Google Plus, so you
can ask us questions during the
event or after the event,
and we'll make sure to answer
your questions.
And also, throughout the slide
deck, you'll see the goo.gl
link at the bottom.
You can head there, and
there's a moderator--
it's a Google Moderator page
there, so you can actually
submit your questions,
and we'll do some
questions at the end.
We may not get to all of them,
but we'll try our best.
All right, so let's
get right into it.
Lots of stuff to cover.
So I'll start with the most
obvious thing that I think
needs to be put up front, which
is just your typical
development cycle.
Right?
So as a web designer, website
owner, you usually go through
three typical steps, right?
You write code, or you
optimize your page.
You test it, hopefully.
Hopefully you have things like
unit tests, integration tests,
to make sure that your sites are
broken, given the updates.
You may even have performance
or regression tests.
So perhaps a new feature that
you have introduced--
is it causing some other
behaviors that may
slow down your site?
That's a good thing to catch.
Visual inspection and Q&A. So I
think a lot of people today
depend on Q and A, just
in terms of like,
does my site work?
Does it work fast enough?
But here's the trick, at
least in my experience.
Then I deploy my code, and maybe
it just says more about
my development skills than
anything else, but whenever I
deploy my code, then I get a
bunch of phone calls or emails
and stuff like this, which just
says, like, oh, yeah,
that's cool that it works
for you, but it
doesn't work for me.
Or for some reason, it
just feels slower.
Which is even worse, because
when something is broken, you
can at least say
what is broken.
When something is just slow,
it's like, well, there's a
million things that could
have gone wrong, right?
And the one thing that I've
learned over time is my
computer, and my device, is
completely different from my
customer's device.
This may seem completely
obvious, but I think it's
worth stating.
And there's a huge, huge
number of factors
that go into this.
So, first of all, I may be
testing my new site on a
Chrome book or my desktop
computer, and you're trying to
access the site on your
mobile phone.
All right?
Two completely different classes
of devices, different
CPU power, amount of memory,
even the network, right?
So loading a bunch of images on
my desktop computer may not
be a big deal.
But loading the same images
on a mobile connection may
actually be pretty painful.
So the one thing that I've
learned, and I think that the
web optimization community at
large is working on today, is
making sure that we measure
real performance from real
users as they interact with your
real site on real network
conditions.
That's a lot of reals
in there.
Keeping it real.
So because of that,
we invented RUM.
Except not this kind of rum.
And we didn't really invent it,
because all it stands for
is Real User Measurement,
right?
And this is what I mean by,
this may seem completely
obvious to somebody in the
analytics space, because it's
like, of course.
How else do you get the data?
You gather it from
the real users.
But in the context of web
performance, or any sort of
performance optimization,
historically, we relied on
synthetic testing.
So I would do a benchmark on my
own computer, or set up a
test that will perhaps even hit
my website from different
geographic locations
in the world.
But the key point there is, it's
not based on real user
behavior, or even real user
browsers and all these things.
That type of data has been
actually very hard to gather,
because we haven't had the
tools to actually get the
performance data from
our browser.
Like how long did it take to
connect to the server, and all
of these things?
So that's what Real User
Measurement is all about, and
you guys can find this acronym
RUM in a lot of places as you
get kind of deeper into the
web performance field.
So the good news is, there's
been a lot of work and effort
put together by the W3C web
performance working group.
So the group started about two
years ago, and they've been
working on a number of different
new specifications
and APIs to enable better tools,
and just better browser
performance.
And specifically, they come up
with this really scary looking
diagram here, which is the
W3C navigation spec.
Now, there's a lot of labels in
here, and the labels don't
really matter for the purposes
of our discussion.
What is important, though,
is the three colors
that we have in here.
The first one is the green one,
which is the network.
And then you have the server
and the browser.
And what this tells you is for
any page that you load in the
browser, there are three
broad components
that come into play.
First of all, there's is the
network, which is how are you
accessing the page?
So me accessing the page on my
mobile phone versus my desktop
computer are two entirely
different experiences, and a
lot of that is due to different
network conditions.
Then there's the server.
So the server can be
really fast, or it
can be kind of slow.
Never happen to me.
And then the last one is the
browser, which is, once the
server sends all of this data
and delivers it over the
network, the browser actually
needs to interpret all of
those data and kind of lay
it out on the screen.
And increasingly, we're
putting more and more
JavaScript into our pages to
make it more interactive.
So that stuff also takes time.
So really, all of these black
labels in here, what they tell
you is, for each of these
labels, the browser actually
captures a time stamp when the
page is rendered, and it
allows us to introspect into
this entire workflow for any
page and see how long
each step took.
Right?
So this is really awesome,
because up until maybe a year
ago, we didn't even have
this capability.
The only thing we could measure,
at best, is some
timing in the browser, but we
didn't see or didn't have any
visibility into the network.
So the cool thing is, if you're
using Chrome, Firefox,
or IE, you can actually open
your developer tools, and type
in your console, performance
and timing.
And you'll get this
object back.
And some of these
labels here--
actually, all of them--
correspond to the labels
that we saw on
the previous diagram.
And you know the W3C guys are
serious about web performance,
because they actually went for
the microsecond granularity.
Not even milliseconds.
Forget milliseconds.
We're optimizing at microsecond
level here.
And so you can open this console
on any web page that
you're browsing currently
and type this in.
And these are the stats
for your connection.
For your browser.
Right?
This is not some generic number
that's coming from the
server itself.
So that's the big change.
Up until very recently,
we just didn't have
access to this data.
And when I say we, as
in web developers.
So the good news is that
navigation timing is now
supported in more than
half of all the
browsers, so about 64%.
Chrome, Firefox, IE--
we have growing support for
mobile browsers as well, so we
have Android browsers,
Chrome, and Firefox.
The one omission right now is
the Safari browsers, so I
think they're catching
up at this point.
But the point is, it's not 100%
deployed yet, but it's
getting there.
So that's the good news.
And the reason I think this is
important, and why RUM real
user measurement is important,
is it's great to read the
latest in terms of top 10
things you should do to
optimize your site, or the top
10 performance improvements.
But frankly, your site
is different.
Your audience may be different,
and your goals may
be different.
It may not actually
matter to you.
So what these metrics allow you
to do is actually measure
all those things with respect
to your goals.
Like, is it even worth that
I spend half a day
micro-optimizing this
specific thing?
Because maybe if it doesn't make
a bottom line impact on
my business, maybe I should work
on my marketing instead.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Yeah.
You have to take it with
a grain of salt, right?
You need to be able to compare
the benefit of every
optimization.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Exactly.
Right.
So that's the key aspect here.
So how do we collect navigation
timing data?
Remember that this data is
available in the browser, so
during each session.
And that's where Google
Analytics comes in.
And the cool thing about this is
there's just 10 easy steps
to get navigation timing
working with GA.
The first step is you log in
to your existing Google
Analytics account, and the
second is you navigate to the
site speed overview.
And actually, at that
point, you're done.
So I'm just using
binary notation.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: You pulled the
super nerd trick, didn't you?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: You
went there.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes.
I thought was funny when I
was making the slides.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Well, you
bring up a great point.
Really, the nice thing about
having that specification is
because all that data is already
in the browser, Google
Analytics can collect
it automatically.
So there's already
reports built.
You don't need to do anything
special other than use your
Google Analytics account, and
just log in, and you're going
to have this data.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
This is why I love talking about
this stuff, because--
JUSTIN CUTRONI: It's
just there.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I always start
the conversation with, like,
here is all the things you
need to do to enable
navigation timing or
gather this data.
And oh, by the way, you
already have it.
So after you finish listening to
this webcast, you can turn
around to your coworker and be
like, hey, I just set up real
user measurement.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Actually, you
could just do it right now.
You could listen to us, and
you could be in Google
Analytics in another monitor,
or on another screen.
That would be even cooler.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So Google
Analytics automatically
collects all this
data for you.
You don't have to do anything.
There's one caveat, and we'll
get back to it in a second,
but let's go and do
an actual demo.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Let's
look at some data.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So let me just
switch to our tab over here.
So this is my own personal
account.
This is data for my own blog.
And what you see here is I just
went into content, site
speed, and overview.
Right?
So I'm just looking at
my regular profile.
And we're looking at about--
well, the last 30
days of data.
July 14th to today.
So you can see that over the
last 30 days, I've had 50,000
page views.
And this graph right here shows
you the average page
loading time.
So this is gathered through
navigation timing.
And average page loading time
is the time when the spinner
stops on your browser.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: It's
pretty detailed.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
There's many different ways.
I think it's important
to define
when the page is loaded.
You don't have to wait for the
spinner to stop, because
oftentimes the content's already
visible, and you can
start interacting with it.
But that's what this specific
metric tells you.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: And this is a
great point to stop for a
second and say that we have a
lot of different metrics in
here that are collected
from the browser.
They match up perfectly with
that diagram that Ilya
provided about the various
points from server to network
to browser.
And so if you are looking for
a definition, we have a help
center for Google Analytics that
defines what all of our
metrics are so that you can get
detailed information about
what does this metric mean in
terms of time measurement in
my browser versus time
measurement at the server
level versus time measurement
about some network attribute?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
And it's very useful to actually
then go back to that
kind of scary-looking diagram
and just see where or at which
point each one of these labels
correspond to because I think
that really helps you build a
visual model of like, where is
my problem, if you will?
Where is the performance
bottleneck?
So on the overview page, you
just get a quick summary of
the key metrics.
Things like the domain look-up
time or the DNS time that it
took to resolve your site.
So perhaps your DNS provider is
not very good, as in it's
slow, right?
So that would show up here.
And that's a very good sign that
you may want to look into
a different provider.
Server response time.
So this is interesting because
I think this comes as news to
a lot of people.
It's like, Google Analytics
can measure my
server response time?
I thought I had to look
at my logs for that.
It's like, well, not anymore,
because we have this data,
which is great.
And we also have
other metrics.
So this is the high
level overview.
We can also go and drill down
into the page timings.
So in here, because Google
Analytics collects the data on
per-page level, you actually
get all this data in any
granularity that you want.
So we were just looking
at your global stats
for the last 30 days.
You can also drill down into
any specific page here.
So, for example, this latency
post that I published a few
weeks back, right?
It had 13,000 page views, and
you can see that on average,
it took about six seconds
to load this page.
Pretty slow.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: And so for all
of you folks that are not
familiar with analytics, we just
call this drilling down
segmentation.
And so what we're doing is we're
taking that top level
number, and we're kind of going
into it to look at one
smaller piece and understand
how that smaller piece is
performing.
And that's a critical, critical
thing in analytics
because making these incremental
changes ultimately
adds to a bigger benefit
to your website.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
Exactly.
So in here, we can
also drill in.
So we're looking at page views,
average page load
time-- but what about
the other metrics?
So you can go into the technical
drill down here.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: You
want technical?
We've got technical.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, we've
got technical.
That's for sure.
And you see just for this
specific page, averages for
loading time, redirection
time, look up times, 50
different times.
And then you can graph, or you
can compare these metrics
against any other metric that
you have in Google Analytics,
which is really cool.
So we're looking at all pages
versus any specific page.
So that's kind of
one first tip.
Now, the second one is, let's
go into performance here.
So averages are very good and
useful, but they can be
misleading.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Absolutely.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Especially
when you talk about web
performance.
Because what you find is,
you'll get skewed
distributions.
You have kind of peaks
and valleys.
And when you just compute
an average of it, it may
completely hide the
entire story.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: It's like the
average net worth of me and
Bill Gates is--
well, Bill kind of skews that
average higher than-- you
know, or I bring
it down lower.
Whichever way you want
to look at it.
But the outliers skew things.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Exactly.
So the histograms allow you to
actually see the underlying
distribution of the data.
So you can see here, we're
looking at the
page loading time.
And within the page
loading time, we
have different buckets.
So 33% of all the users loaded
the page in sub 1 second.
And we can actually expand this
bucket even further and
look as to what the
breakdown is here.
43% loaded the page in within
one to three seconds.
So this is very useful
information.
And you can do this sort of
drill down for any specific
metric in here.
And I'll show you guys a side
by side comparison of one
specific case, which I think
is really important.
So let me go back to
this next tab.
So what you're looking at here
is my site, and the data is
from January 1 to January 31.
So we actually went
back in time.
And the reason I'm showing this
is it just so happens
that on December 31--
that's what I do, I guess,
on my holidays--
I completely migrated
my site to a
different hosting provider.
I completely rewrote how the
data's served and everything.
I guess that's my holiday.
And I know that I made that
cut-off on December 31.
So what I want to show you
here is, this is the data
after I migrated.
Now, let's select this, and I'll
do compare to the past.
So I want to compare January
to December.
Did all this work that I did--
do, I guess-- on December 31
amount to much, or not?
So I'll compare this, and now
we have two lines here.
It may not be immediately
obvious what the difference
is, but now look
at the metrics.
My average page loading
time went down by 25%.
My server response
time went by 76%.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Awesome.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So this is a huge improvement.
I can actually show you the
data and quantify it, and
everything's green.
So to me, this is like,
huge success.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: And the
measurement was easy, right?
What did you have to do to--
I didn't have to do anything.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: You didn't
have to do anything.
That's the best part.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
Exactly.
So let me just go back here.
So as I was exploring these
reports, frankly, I didn't
even realize that Google
Analytics was collecting this
data at first.
And then I found these things,
and I was like,
wow, this is awesome.
But the light bulb moment for
me was not when I was just
browsing through these reports,
but when I realized
that I have all the power
of Google Analytics.
So, as an example, we can look
at the map overlay here.
And what this shows you is for
every visitor that comes to my
site, Google Analytics collects
geo information.
And we can then cross-reference
that.
So it may be a little bit hard
to see, but the colors on the
map here correspond to the
amount of time that it took to
load the page.
So there's a couple of
countries in here--
specifically Iraq and Syria--
where, on average, the pages
take 105 seconds to load.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: That's
a long time.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
I don't think I've ever
waited 105 seconds
for a page to load.
So what this tells me is most
likely, there's some asset on
my site, or some JavaScript
resource that is probably even
just blocked.
And because of that, the
user gets a blank page.
Then that thing times out, and
then they get the page, which
is a terrible experience.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Very bad.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right?
So that's something for
me to look into.
But now let's go back here.
You're looking at the page views
here, which is sort of
what I want.
Let me go back to overview.
So we have average
page load time.
Now, advanced segments is like,
oh my god moment for me.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Yeah.
If you've never used Analytics,
advanced segments
is one of the most powerful
features of this tool, where
you can basically segment the
data in real time, right?
And segmentation is similar to
filtering, but you could say,
show me all mobile traffic, and
Google Analytics will, in
real time, filter your
data for you.
Or show me all my mobile traffic
coming from Syria, or
show me all my mobile traffic
coming from North America.
So you can pretty much drill
into the data almost an
infinite number of ways in
order to analyze the
performance of certain segments
of your traffic,
which is really valuable
here, right?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
Exactly.
And so the key point here is,
you don't need to know these
things up front.
You can just apply this stuff.
So, for example, I want to
compare the average page
loading time between, let's say,
North and South America
versus Asia.
So I have already created
a custom segment called
Americas, which stands
for North and South.
Now what I want is
Asia as well.
So to do that, I'll create a new
custom segment, and I'll
do a continent containing
Asia, and I'll name
it, and I'll save.
OK.
So we've created the segment,
and I'll just
compare it to this guy.
Apply.
And look at that.
There's a huge difference.
Turns out there's a huge
difference between users
coming from Asia and
users coming from
North or South America.
And that makes sense, because
my server happens to be
located about 200 miles from
where we're sitting here in
California, so it makes sense
that users in North America
get a faster experience.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: And what's
interesting is, remember, all
of these metrics tell you a
different part of the story in
terms of a page loading
in someone's browser.
Part of the story is what's
happening at the network
level, part of the story is
what's happening at the sever
level, and part of the story
is what's happening in the
browser level.
So Ilya, you may have a really
long time for the page to
load, but your server response
might be fast, or the DNS
lookup might be fast.
So that gives you tips
into what the
optimization might be.
Like you mentioned before, it
might be, I need to get a
better DNS provider so the
lookup happens faster.
Or if it's your page is really
crappy and it takes a lot of
time to render in the browser,
that's something that you can
go ahead and work on.
ILYA GRIGORIK: You can do
a ton of forensics.
So for example, here you
have this giant spike.
And the natural question
would be, well, why
did it take 16 seconds?
So maybe I can create a new
segment, mobile versus desktop
in Asia, and kind of just
drill in and find
out the root cause.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: More
segmentation.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
It's what it's all about.
So we already talked
about this.
Just a quick note.
So this is a side by side
comparison between December
and January.
This is what I meant by
averages can lie.
You have two completely
different kind of bimodal
distributions here.
So make sure to pay attention
to these things.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: So this
has been awesome.
And you guys don't know Ilya,
Ilya is like, performance
super nerd.
Loves this stuff.
And he makes it contagious.
I'm actually doing a whole bunch
of speed optimization on
my own website now.
But in my work in analytics,
I talk to a
lot of business people.
A lot of marketers, a lot of
advertisers who are happy to
talk to Ilya and hear about this
amazing speed stuff, but
they're like, yeah, I need
to make some money.
So the best part about analytics
is, it's all about
your business, right?
And in Google Analytics, we
really stress to people that
you have to measure what's
important to your business.
What is the desired outcome
that you have?
Whether it's on your desktop
website or your mobile website
or even your app, we want you
to think about what am I
trying to do?
What is the core business
objective of my site, my
mobile site, or my app?
And when you boil down the
entire internet, there's
really only five types
of business models.
I might be trying to sell a
product, generate some type of
lead, I may be a publisher
trying to generate revenue
from ads, I may be trying to
provide support to a group, or
I might be out there trying
to build my brand.
And so with Google Analytics,
we can track all of those
different types of objectives.
And we use a feature
called Goals.
The really, really important
thing is that you take the
time to sit down and define
what is your objective and
what are your goals and make
sure you configure Google
Analytics in order to
track those things.
Because if you don't, you're
really just tracking a whole
bunch of data that, while it is
useful, it doesn't help you
understand the impact
to your business.
So we've got a whole bunch of
videos on the Google Analytics
YouTube channel about how to set
up goals in your account.
And what I want to do here is
tell you a little bit about
how you can configure Google
Analytics to take the awesome
speed data that Ilya showed you
and compare it to some of
the conversion data and revenue
data that you can
collect with Google Analytics.
And why are we doing this?
Well, again, you talk to the
speed guys, and their
objective is they want
to make the web fast.
And there's a good reason to do
that, because there's been
a lot of studies that show the
slower your website is, the
lower your conversion
rate's going to be.
The more trouble your website
visitors are going to have in
reaching their objective, or
your business objective,
whether that's buying
a product or
submitting a lead form.
And so there's been a number of
studies by companies like
Gomez and Akamai and Tagman
that have shown a drop-in
conversion rate the longer
it takes for pages to
render on your site.
And again, it's not
just render.
You have to kind of think of
that whole process of the
network, the server, and the
browser generating that page
for the visitor.
So there is financial proof
here, conversion proof, that
if you speed things up, you're
going to do better.
You're going to create a better
experience for your
website visitors, and ultimately
that's going to
lead to an increase in
business for you.
So how might we do some
of these things?
Well, the reports that we looked
at before in Google
Analytics about speed
are spot on, right?
They tell you lots of things
about all of the different
speed metrics.
The one thing that they're
missing is they don't have a
lot of data about the
conversions or the revenue
that's in Analytics.
And so when Ilya and I were
talking about doing this
webcast, we talked about some
reports and some ways that we
could customize Google Analytics
in order to generate
that data so you can see
it in one interface.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to jump over to Google
Analytics and walk you guys
through some customization
that's not too advanced.
You can totally do this.
But we want to show you guys
how to make some custom
reports that have all
this great data.
That's it.
Third click.
Awesome.
OK.
So if you've never used Google
Analytics before, we have a
lot of different ways that you
can customize the product.
The Advanced Custom Segments--
that's one way that you can
slice and dice your data.
And one of my favorites
is the custom reports.
And the reason why I love custom
reports so much is that
I can get exactly the data I
want in one screen, and I can
build in all sorts of metrics
that help me understand
whatever it is I'm trying
to analyze.
And so this is an account I have
here, and I have a whole
bunch of different
custom reports.
You can see there's many,
many different kinds.
And you can create your own
custom reports by just
clicking on this new custom
report button.
And we'll just walk through
a few basics of this.
I'm going to give my
report a name.
Maybe it's my awesome
speed report.
And within my report, I have
two types of information.
I have metrics and I
have dimensions.
And metrics are just
numbers, right?
So when we were looking
at some of the reports
previously, we were looking at
metrics like DNS response
time, page load time.
And so if you could literally
start to type in here page
load time, and that metric's
going to pop up.
So I can put that
into my report.
And so we have all of
those great speed
metrics we talked about.
I encourage you to
play with this.
But we also have all those
business metrics
that I really like.
So I could type in something
like revenue, which is
amazing, right, because
that tells me how
much money I'm making.
And I have conversion
rate as well.
So I'm going to just type in
goal number seven that I have
configured here.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Maybe just
one quick note.
So revenue's like the
ultimate metric.
Ultimate.
Right?
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Absolutely.
ILYA GRIGORIK: But having said
that, for sites that may not
have a direct conversion
to render.
For example, my own site
is a blog, right?
I don't have revenue from it.
But I do have goals defined on
my blog, which are things
like, have you visited
my archive page?
Have you subscribed
to my RSS feed?
So I could also use those
metrics in here, right?
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Absolutely.
Just because you don't sell a
product, it doesn't mean you
don't have goals for
your website.
It just means those goals
are different.
So like you said, if
you're a blogger--
I'm a blogger myself, and the
objective of my blog is to
connect with people.
And so my goals might be around
people connecting with
me via social media through the
blog, or people submitting
contact forms.
So that's why the whole process
of aligning the Google
Analytics data with your
business is really important,
and we do that through
these goals.
So if you don't have any goals
set up, you're really missing
out on the best data.
You could measure visits, and
pages per visit, and time, and
all those standard things.
But you really have to distill
it down to what am I trying to
do with this blog?
What is the value that I'm
trying to get out of this?
So we can add a lot
of different
metrics here to our report.
And again, metrics around
revenue and conversions, so no
matter what the site does.
And I can then add in a whole
bunch of different dimensions.
And dimensions are just--
really, they're attributes
of a visit, right?
So they could be the page the
visitor's looking at, it could
be the country the visitor
came from--
I can put almost anything
in here.
So let's just put in country.
And so what will happen is
Google Analytics will build
out this report, and it'll show
me all of my countries,
and then the metrics for
those countries.
So if I click Save--
ILYA GRIGORIK: And this
is all done live.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Yes, exactly.
Live.
So here, now we have a list of
countries, and we have the
metrics that we were
talking about--
average page load time, revenue,
and conversion rate.
Now I'm going to skip to a
similar report here that's
just maybe a little bit more
advanced, because I want to
show you guys a few things.
So I've got countries listed
here in one column, and I've
got a whole bunch of our
different performance metrics,
like load time, domain look
up time, redirect time.
And I've got a couple
of conversions here.
I've got revenue--
the revenue is all zeroes
because I wanted to put
revenue in there just to show
you you could, but I don't
have any revenue configured
on my blog.
But I have this goal of people
actually reading articles.
And so what I can start to do is
start to look and see like,
is there any relationship
between some of the speed
metrics, like domain lookup time
or redirect time, and the
conversion rate that's
happening.
What I think is really
interesting about building
this report out is something we
mentioned before, where you
have metrics for different parts
of the process, right?
So whether it's server, network,
or browser based.
And certain types of things
are dependent on like
geolocation, or they might
be dependent on
the piece of content.
So this report has country
and territory.
And so for those things, I would
be thinking like, oh,
network and server types of
configuration and metrics,
because they're distant,
right?
You said you've only got one
server here in California.
So is there a problem with the
Philippines, or Indonesia, or
someplace that's far away?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So a very
concrete conclusion would have
been, if I was, let's say,
selling something, and I could
show that in Asia, I'm getting
lower conversions and it
corresponds to higher response
times, maybe I get another
server in Asia, or I use a CDN
provider or something similar.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Absolutely.
And so that's the
thing I think is
great about this report.
Now, if you're like me--
I'm the analytics guy.
I have to look at
a lot of data.
Sometimes I can get lazy, and I
want new and different ways
to look at these things.
And so I want to show
you a really great
tip in Google Analytics.
You'll notice here we have a
series of buttons on the top
right part of our table, and I
can change the view of my data
into something called the
performance view.
And this allows me to literally,
like visually, in
green and red, see what's
good or bad.
So I can say, all right, I want
to look at the average
domain lookup here, and I can
see that time for these
different countries.
And I'm going to switch this
over to my conversion rate.
Now, this is kind of hard.
Red means something's really
bad, and green mean
something's OK.
So now my analysis is basically,
good, bad, bad,
good, bad, good, bad,
good, bad, bad.
Done.
Now, I can go to my speed expert
Ilya here, and he can
optimize the domain lookup
time for all of those
different countries.
And the first thing he can do is
be like, dude, I don't care
about Malaysia.
We're not doing business
in Malaysia.
It's not really a big deal.
But I really do care
about France.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Although we
do care about Malaysia.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: We do
care about Malaysia,
we do, in real life.
But you could look at other--
like Canada, why are
you so slow?
Or Morocco?
You can look at these other
geographic locations, and this
is showing you that the
conversion rate-- because it's
like, literally,
it's red here--
for those types of
places is lower.
So I've got over 100
rows of data.
I can expand this
out and look.
But I really like this
visualization.
And I can change this metric in
the first column to be any
of the metrics that
I configured
in this custom report.
And again, this can be any of
these speed-related metrics.
And now I have a nice visual way
of seeing the relationship
between a speed metric and an
end business result, which, I
mean, to me--
ILYA GRIGORIK: This is an
awesome bridge, right?
Because for somebody who's
responsible for the bottom
line of the business, you can
actually now connect it to
speed, and be like,
this is why I need
to optimize my site.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Totally.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And vice versa,
if I'm a developer, I can look
at this data and show my bottom
line guy that hey, we
really need to invest into
web optimization.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Absolutely.
And one thing I'll just
show you guys.
This report--
I have actually created
this report, and
this tab has geodata.
But I've got other tabs.
I've got other tabs that show
this data segmented by the
different browsers.
And so on this tab, instead
of having things like
server-related metrics, or
network related metrics, I can
have browser-related metrics.
And now I can look at each
browser and do the same type
of analysis.
And I can actually add a layer
of detail where for each
browser, if I click on it, I can
break that browser down by
the pages that were displayed
via that browser.
And so now I'm doing that
drilling down, that
segmentation, that helps me
understand like, this page in
this browser might be
really, really bad.
And I can switch over, and
again, do my conversion or my
revenue-type comparison using
that visualization.
So this is a really
handy report.
We've got a little treat for you
about it at the end of the
presentation.
But play with the
custom reports.
Go build some custom reports
around your speed metrics and
various dimensions that they're
appropriate for, and
you'll be amazed at
what you find.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Awesome.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: So let's
go back to the
presentation, maybe.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So we have just a few
more quick tips.
So I think we talked
about all of this.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Yeah, these
were just backup slides.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Always good
to have a backup.
Right?
So yes, this is an awesome,
awesome report.
You can also build your
own dashboard.
So unlike a custom report, this
is just kind of a quick
way to assemble a bunch
of metrics.
And so a couple of
very quick tips.
So, by default, Google Analytics
does not sample the
navigation timing data
from 100% of users.
It's set to 1%.
Now, there is a limit to how
much data you can collect,
which is 10,000 samples a day.
So my tip is-- and this
is something that
I've done on my site--
is in your Google Analytics
configuration code, if your
site is below 10,000 visits, you
can actually increase your
sampling rate.
So actually, you
have more data.
So that's one thing you should
probably do if you don't have
a lot of traffic like my site.
So you can set your site speed
sample rate to 100%.
Second thing that I've
done for my site--
you can take any of these
reports, you can create a PDF
report that just gets emailed
to you every week.
So every Monday, you get an
email which I just look at
which shows me if anything
bad has happened.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: And what's
really cool is that you can
create an automated email
report, send a PDF format of
the custom report that we just
looked at that has the
business data in there.
And that's something that maybe
I'm not going to look at
every day, but I might look
at that weekly or monthly
depending on how
big my site is.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Exactly.
It's just a very easy way to
keep tabs on this thing.
And then the last tip is if
you're doing performance
optimization, one thing that
I find very, very useful is
adding annotations on a graph.
So it's a little bit hard to
see here, but if you expand
the annotation bar, you can
actually add your own notes in
there such that when you see
that peak or valley in the
graph, you can then go back and
be like, oh, yeah, that's
when I did that crazy thing,
and now everything's fast.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Yeah.
Annotations are a really,
really important thing.
The great thing about
annotations are they're shared
across your Google Analytics
account, so if a
businessperson like me logs in,
I can see an annotation
that Ilya left that said,
hey, we added a
new server in Malaysia.
And that might be great, because
that might have been
the date that my conversion rate
started to increase, or--
ILYA GRIGORIK: By the way,
I make your site fast.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Yeah, he just
types in optimize site.
So we showed you guys some
customizations, and we're just
going to give those to you.
So these links that are here
on the screen will, if you
type them into your browser,
they will automatically open
up Google Analytics and they'll
ask you if you'd like
to add them into your Google
Analytics account.
So there's the business impact
of speed-- that's the custom
report that I was showing
you guys.
So it's got a number of metrics
along with your
conversio-type metrics.
There is a little bit
of customization
you'll need to do.
Make sure you have goals set
up in Google Analytics, and
make sure that you choose
your goals for
that particular report.
But other than that, that's
all you need to do.
We created a site performance
dashboard that has a lot of
just the general metrics
around how your site's
performing.
That's a great one if you're
into speed, if you're into
site performance to use every
day, and you can automate the
delivery of that via email so
you get it every morning.
Don't even need to log in
to GA, which is great.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So, Justin, I
think just because we're so
excited, we kind of went
over time here.
So there are some questions.
I'm not sure if we're
going to have much
time to get into the--
let me see.
Where are we?
Here we go.
If we can't answer the question
right now, then we'll
follow up on Google+, so feel
free to ping us there.
But I think there's a few that
we can answer quickly.
So this question I think I can
take, which is, Google APIs
are really, really powerful,
but JavaScript makes
potentially my site slower.
Should I be using it?
And the answer there is, you
should absolutely use the
HTML5 five features in a
browser, because unlike trying
to fill in different
capabilities within
JavaScript, when you have
capabilities right in a
browser, they will go faster.
You shouldn't be scared of using
JavaScript, especially
if that's what makes
your site tick.
So measure these things.
That's probably the most
important message, or the
answer there.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Yeah,
and maybe we'll
just take one more.
This one looks like it's
right up my alley.
When using the site speed report
in Google Analytics,
how can we analyze the potential
amount of sales lost
due to the site being
x seconds slow?
Well, we really can't show you
the potential amount of sales.
We can't model what
might happen.
But using that custom report
that has the revenue from your
website in it along with some
of the other performance
metrics, you'll be able to see
if there's a relationship
between something that has
poor performance and the
amount of revenue that
it generates.
So while it can't show you the
loss, you can use that as a
baseline for optimization.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I'll just
make a quick note.
Google actually did some tests
on our search pages where we
actually made this search
slower, right?
And we tracked the
impact of that.
So you could actually
do the same thing.
This is kind of a weird
request to go to your
developer and say, hey--
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Slow
the site down.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Let's run an AB
test and make part of the
experience slower.
So you could quantify this
if you wanted to.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: I think that's
actually all we have time for.
Like we said, ping either
of us through Google+.
The Google Analytics, we
have a page as well.
And we'll try to bang out
some of these after this
[INAUDIBLE].
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep,
and we'll post the
responses on the Moderator.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Absolutely.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Great.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Great.
Thank you, guys.
JUSTIN CUTRONI: Thanks,
everybody.